he's Doug Gottlieb from CBS sports
they're college basketball analyst
favorite cliche this time of the year is
what Doug I be all about guard play the
that's probably the big one or or
something about coaches like you point
out is though and I like to say like
january/february is though but they just
got beaten the first round of the
tournament last year like nobody like
everybody press just delete on that one
so like the coaches are great but
they're not
we still need a player to come down and
make a play at the end of the game but
would you pick your brackets how much
would you rely on who is the coach
there's some to it or some to it but
there's also I like to meet in the
reality of it it's really more about
matchups and anything else it's like I
like Sean like I think Sean Miller is a
spectacular coach I think his team's get
tight in the biggest of games because he
hasn't gotten to that final four but I
look for the type of team the type of
style matchup zone or sagging man-to-man
that can match up with the athleticism I
don't see it this year I also think that
they have a star on the inside you know
that big kid he can shoot the power
Lowry marketin yes he's finished
he's spectacular and so that does change
them so coaching sometimes does play a
factor and there is something to every
year the same coaches seem to be at the
Final Four or close to the Final Four
but it's not always the deciding factor
you know you got got to have some
jimmies and Joe's not just X denotes
there's another one right there
right but I look there's some coaches
there that we you're like no there's no
like Florida State is the all airport
team like they walk in they walked in
here you like what NBA team is that and
Leonard Hamilton is a wonderful human
being I have zero faith that that team
would get to the Final Four and
talent-wise they should be in
consideration I just whatever it is
between the the style of play the talent
that they have there's some sort of
disconnect there to which and they
should have when VCU went to the final
floor they were the better team they
were a shot of way that probably should
have been there so maybe I'm I'm holding
that against him but I just I watched
him play over the weekend it did
reaffirm my feelings that the coach like
that there's a limitation that I think
people make the mistake of saying oh
this is why
open there are so many teams who could
win the national title and my point is
how many can win six in a row the
difference yes I think there's a bunch
of teams that can get could
theoretically get to the FOA four could
theoretically get to the Final Four and
you have to still win two more after
that right like it's a weird year like
here's a perfect example like Butler
loses to Indiana State like Butler loses
at home to Georgetown
Butler swept Villanova this year like
it's that kind of year at Kansas lost at
home to Iowa State like it's it's a
weird year but it's not so weird that if
you pick Duke you're not crazy Duke to
me this year is like USC and football
this year where everybody knew if they
got it together they figured it out that
they probably have the best players to
go along with a historically good coach
and Jason Tatum is the is the Sam Donald
of college basketball in I you know Phil
Jackson supposedly is hey we got to do
whatever it takes to get Jason Tatum
there's other really good players and it
is a deeper draft but Tatum is that good
and you know grace now who everybody
loves to hate super talented when they
came from behind at the end of beat
Notre Dame in the AC he wasn't on the
floor now like they're actually better
without him at times so it's not crazy
to pick Duke & Duke becomes the most
polarizing team it's everybody's
national celebration is selection sunday
and when Duke lose in the NCAA
tournament would this be the most
obnoxious Duke national championship
team most obnoxious well I mean
Christian Laettner and Bobby Hurley I
don't know I mean and then Christian
Laettner running away with people's
money afterwards only reaffirms
everything you thought about christian
Laettner wait a minute ran away with
other people's money he's being sued
right now for for personal business oh
oh oh but that I'm saying like 20 years
later like I still say Christian
Laettner I was thinking he took his
teammates mono no no no no well uh it
would it would be up there it would be
up there but like look they had it's big
I guess because of the Grayson Allen
thing it would the truth is that like
Luke Canard dude that's that's a fun
player to watch play Jason Tatum is a
fun player to watch play the Harry Giles
thing is interesting I here's a kid
top five high school American has two
knee surgeries so he doesn't play for a
couple years it's it's been hard to
watch him considering what he was before
injury but he's slowly but surely coming
along and he's shown some strides like I
kind of root for Harry job so I don't
know to me I disconnect from the emotion
of trying to hate Duke I like the kids I
want to see them grow and evolve and and
I do think that social media has made it
worse although grace now has allowed us
to pile on with some of the nonsense
that he's done if I said to Coach K
privately do you want Grayson Allen to
stay one more year or go oh that's a
great question I would say he'd probably
want him to stay this has been a very
very difficult year for him and the
immaturity shown in the fits the hissy
fits on and off the court I think he'd
probably say he'd want him to say I'm
watching you play against North Carolina
what was interesting is that we focus on
canard and Grayson Allen and you
mentioned Tatum brings them back but
it's still the focus is on Grayson Allen
and canard who did play better in the
second half in Grayson Allen had quite a
few three Commander - Tatum's best
player on the floor yes but he remember
when Grayson Allen was up for Player of
the Year to start that year and I went
he's not the best player his own team
well that's he's not even the best white
kid on his own like gloop-gloop Kanaka
dart is better play that's hot but again
that's one of those things to which at
some point we have to put yourself in
Grayson Allen's body right like as a
freshman you sat you got in you played
you starred national championship and
you win it last year it's your team this
year like I am coming back it's my team
we got these young guys and then all of
a sudden like Luke cannot you're like
Luke canards better than me Luke canards
get more attention he's getting more
love he's moving up the draft boards
like it I'd love to say that I would
have the maturity at 21 that I
supposedly have at 41 but I I wouldn't I
would be pissed too and I would struggle
when everybody's calling me a thug and a
bat-like so I don't know if I would
handle it like him but I do understand
some of emotionally what he's going
through we'll come back with Doug will
look at conspiracy theories here we'll
look at the tournament I can prove to
you why there is no conspiracy theory
and I can prove to you why the narrative
that the mid-majors are
shaft in Oakland Arkin correct there you
go Doug providing a tease here on the
Dan Patrick show after this hahahahaha
you know I read something on the
internet Baldy
about Doug really the Doug is leaving
CBS now yes yeah that's what I read that
real new is that fake news I think it
might be real news that Doug is leaving
and going to Fox sources close to me
tell me but Doug's not allowed to talk
about anything it's been a no comment
that's a no comment okay now all right
so you teased a couple of items before
we went to break here the mid-majors did
not get job this year
no that's because we've forgotten who
the mid-majors are right like Gonzaga
used to be a mid-major right or VCU
Wichita Wichita State and Dayton heck
you know you know Butler like Butler is
in the Big East which is kind of
somewhere in between
here's the problem with mid-major okay
the Southern Conference which Davidson
was once in like that's a l'eau major
league right nobody wants to be called
mid-major because outside of high major
everybody's that mid major there's low
major and there's actually super low
major like the SWAC is not really
Division one basketball so when you
start there and you work your way up
there's still plenty of mid-majors
non-high majors non-power five leads in
lucca and so if you look I mean kind of
look through the bracket here and you
start to see that Butler gets in as a
four-seat now part of that is their
success and they're again like a quasi
low high major if you will but they're
not they don't have a budget of Indiana
and Purdue they don't have those the the
reach of that they don't have the
practice gym the facilities they're in a
very good league they beat Villanova
twice but they're still they're still
kind of Butler they're still kind of
recruiting from a little bit better pool
than they were when they were in Horizon
League which is a low major so again
look through it and I think the reality
of it is whether it's SMU who was a
mid-major
who is a very incredible they're
basically Virginia defensively they're
incredible defensively
there's SMU or Providence or Marquette
like nobody wants to be called mid-major
but are they mid majors they're the old
definition of mid-majors is which is
what we do what to you
that's probably if you go back to
Wichita State a couple of years ago
Gonzaga in the in the infancy they were
certainly considered a mid-major George
Mason was a I think it was more a kind
of classic midbass okay so so these
teams are above that level like Wichita
State for example they're playing Greg
Greg Marshalls making four million
dollars okay but as good as their team
is and they got screwed that was not
fair what they now you got date it
wasn't fair today neither daintiness is
seven she just got Wichita State 130
games okay here's the thing Wichita
State I agree that their seed and they
do do the seeds one through 68 so they
actually put it they create that but
they don't but a region wise do they do
it like they do one through 68 yeah and
that's how we came upon our that's how a
campfire sees one through four that a
lot of it is also we're going to put you
know Kentucky they want them they want
teams closer to home even though yo
seeds who want you closer to home but is
that fair look I would like it if they
just made made up I completely disagree
with you I like look just make up the
matchup so people want to see what you
can but you violated the seedings though
bear-like one seed line here oh are
there because they have they have rules
they want to keep it close to home you
don't play a conference foe or remand
everybody know all this yes the coaches
all notice yeah do the coaches know
exactly what the committee is looking
for no because but why not because you
can't
yy-your like they change the rules every
year Doug here's why there's ten people
okay and they say like look strength of
schedule non-conference chance for
schedule at the end of the day you have
a list of teams there's ten you got to
pick five okay you can take whatever
factor you want you can say I don't like
that guy I saw you know we do the eye
test the eye test was basically I saw a
team like if you saw Syracuse play
against Georgia Tech in their last
regular season game bike that's
tournament team or you ain't Jones if
you saw him st. John's it gives you like
33 points no home floor yes in your mind
like they lost to Boston College if
that's the worst ACC team I have ever
seen and they're better this year than
they were last year
you can't lose the Boston College but
you saw him against Georgia Tech you saw
them to come back against Duke it's when
did you see them would you put in
somebody in because of what you think
they'll do or because of what they've
done
if no one is biggest sighting factor no
look last year I sat on that on that
desk and I said they don't belong in but
they're going to be dating and they
probably would have won a game or two
this year at some point it should like
it's what are we trying to find we try
and find the best teams and we try and
shine the teams that earned it my thing
with Syracuse is this this year two and
11 on the road and both those two wins
we're against teams who didn't make the
tournament Clemson or Carolina State and
they were miracles that they've won
those games who you are on the road is
really who you are didn't beat anybody
in the non-conference it didn't beat
anybody of any substance in the non comp
but how do you I want to know and then I
saw them against Miami the last game in
the ACC tournament and I just I wanted
to see something I want to see guys dive
in the floor guys dying to win the game
right I want to win this game they win
that game the NCAA I just didn't see it
I'm like buying if it comes down to I
want to know what you did or I want to
know I'm going to project how well we
think you'll do in a tournament because
we've seen teams because if it happens
in all sports
yeah project I know but you have to
because we project if you have an injury
like Oregon yeah Oregon gets a big
injury that's that effect force [ __ ]
yan'er well after that affects them so
you're factoring in what you think
they'll do because they just lost our
best big man it's fair except for how
can i how can I know what Syracuse is
going to do right Syracuse is like oh
well they beat yeah they lost five of
the last seven games of the season okay
but they don't hazard to get in okay but
so so what they didn't do anything but
we've seen teams that do well even your
seeding you know Duke I mean what more
do you want out of Duke to end their den
the year just no way for you to
determine what I think a team is going
to do Michigan State last year won the
Big Ten Tournament number two seat they
don't they they take a dump and lose
them Middle Tennessee snakes up their
game title that's official yeah that'll
be the finish I think it's I think it's
a really hard thing anyway the thing is
do they have all these metrics they do
but the end of the day like do the
metrics matter as much as I saw this
team and I'm convinced it's like like
look I think the Big East got to benefit
the fact that early in the season
Creighton was legit and Xavier was
really good and Butler has been here and
great and not fully assembled now you
lose one of the best point guards in the
country and it's the easiest pick in the
world to say they're going to lose in
the
around the term Montandon marquette the
only beats Creighton and Xavier when
they're completely depleted until
Marquette ends up getting those wins /
Creighton and Xavier at the end of the
year Provident same thing and that's how
they got to determine it's a really hard
thing with immense okay now that you're
going to Fox you can say whatever you
want because CBS has got no control over
you should Georgetown hire Patrick Ewing
uh I don't believe so
should John Thompson the third be fired
I think he's got to go are you what did
you think of the bob night interview I
thought it was sad I thought it was
really really sad I understand I again I
can understand where he's coming from we
have something that you invested in you
love that was so great that you feel
like it was taken from you but I say
this all the time when you're a child
you point out it's them it's them it's
them when you're don't you point in you
know what some of that was on me I've
made a lot of mistakes in my life and
there are people who have screwed me
over at the end of the day I have eyes
to take some accountability to it he
still doesn't take any accountability
towards what what took place and I don't
think he really wished they actually do
think he really wished death upon people
I just thought was sad because he was a
magnificent basketball coach like my dad
who passed away has notes upon notes he
should do these he's to do these clinics
when he was at Army and coaches would
come from miles around getting the car
same thing at Indiana like he is an
iconic basketball coach he goes to last
undefeated team the history of college
basketball but our lasting memory of him
is going to be one the disaster that was
his run at ESPN and to his radio
interview with you and and your your
friend to coach night and he respect
coach night he did that to himself
you know he didn't have to a couple of
expressions that bother us score the
basketball
what else do you scores yeah score the
ball I can't I got a minute we got to
make shots
I hate we got to make shots yeah no we
got to do got to make shots um pick and
pump taking pop yeah when I'm just like
picking top your you would have been a
picking nowadays in college basketball
you had been a pick and tie it forward
does everybody know pick and pop
apparently not yes so
I don't know if you can keep using
expression if they don't know what it is
that's that's the challenge to being a
really good broadcaster is you mean I'll
tweet something to you I'll show you
there's twisting a ball screen so new
technique that people painful it does it
twisting a balls holy that happen to you
didn't it yeah I had to turn my head and
cough yeah but again if you do it in a
if you if you say that in a game and
you're really good broadcast for you
work with your producing your director
and you get the video to match up to it
like ah can I prove you there so
conspiracy like a Seinfeld character
there won't know that's coming to
America oh my gosh I shall deny the soup
right house all right can I preview the
car can I prove you there's no
conspiracy day okay
okay so the tournament is 80% owned by
Turner Sports right true TV has the
first floor this coming Tuesday and
Wednesday
it would have been ratings bonanza if
Syracuse was in I'd like to put Syracuse
against Providence or Syracuse against
Illinois State like big that's what by
the way which is what the first floor
should be the first floor should be
major conference against mid-major like
I disagree like give me some reason I
want to watch like Syracuse Illinois
State last came in fine
Thunderdome two teams enter one team
leaves that's what I want to see David
Levy is a huge Syracuse wonk he's the
head of all up Turner you don't think
he'd want to see them play on his
network on a Tuesday I really think
Syracuse would be must-see TV for the
nation where we'd go no I gotta see them
not for the nation but of the teams that
that people kept like what are the games
Tuesday USV Providence yeah which which
name I'm interested with USC again I'm
interested too because I think if USC
wins
I think USC beat SMU of Providence wins
SMU wins but that's besides yeah
okay so Syracuse Providence USC Provence
what gets a better number on truTV
Syracuse promise it be the highest-rated
game in the history of truTV so if there
was a conspiracy David Levy picks up the
phone calls the committee and goes look
I paid a hundred billion dollars I want
Syracuse on my network on Tuesday night
only proves that there is no conspiracy
theory my give me the most underrated
overrated team that will do damage in
the tournament most underrated team
well it's a good timing to hit me with I
would say let's start with overrated
because that one to me is easy I'm not
sure Villanova makes it to the second
weekend and if you look at Villanova
they haven't beat any of the top 15
teams in the country they haven't beaten
they're running in on fumes a little bit
and if Wisconsin can survive Virginia
Tech nor Wisconsin upset Xavier last
year in the tournament really good Z
we're going to get credit for this hot
take here yeah I could I could see
Wisconsin who has underachieved
throughout the regular season and I
think they're under seated as an eighth
seed I can see Wisconsin beating
Villanova because I Gil anova Bennett
Villanova doesn't foul wisconsin dells
of how this games gonna move really
quickly if nigel hayes decides to play
in the low post play with some toughness
with constable nick in subby that would
be the overage the underrated well you
look at the teams that are that have the
double-digit seeds that you feel like
got job oklahoma state over Michigan
that's an easy pick to me really really
easy both teams play similar style when
we say it's got got better personnel
Florida Gulf Coast against Florida State
Joe do you call on the shot I call a
shot you're up G FGCU yeah I got FGCU
one time in the middle of nowhere and I
found a way besides either side if you
watch like again Florida State they've
kid Johnson Isaac top 10 NBA draft pick
freshman stud but I just I don't get the
sense that they understand how to win a
game whereas FGCU like this is their
Super Bowl alright let me get one more
item here Lonzo ball is Jason Kidd the
thing about Lonzo ball is is this would
you take him number one no matter what
team it is you'd find a spot for Muse
that great no no what I can't him number
one no I take Markoff Martell faults
before him look I think here's the thing
it depends on the makeup your team I
think he has a chance of he'll will make
everybody else better the way he plays
there's an energy to him the the way his
dad is actually helps him be who he is
accused the opposite of his death yes
he's smart he's kind he's thoughtful
he's he and he loves to win now he
doesn't play defense and he's got some
bad habits he's got a funky shot which
is going to limit him in terms of
mid-range game and shooting off the
balls
some of these little basketball things
but guys are going to love to play with
them I mean like I see the I see the
fact guys are going to run the floor
they'll go for alley-oops like it'll be
fun
Markel folds checks a lot of those boxes
in terms of being a better basketball
player I don't know if he'll make guys
better but he is better and then you got
Jason Tatum you got Lowry marketing you
got versatile big guys who will play
2017 basketball that you'd probably take
ahead of them but if I need a point
guard and I have other guys that I feel
like can make plays around him it would
it's a fun style to play I think that's
when you take a Lanza bulk
he's Doug Gottlieb at least for one more
day with CBS Sports and then heading to
Fox good luck with that move Doug we
appreciate it I appreciate you having me
on the Dan Patrick show weekday morning
on audience